thank you all for coming I am going to
talk to you
involved in in Russia since about two
thousand three it's hard to imagine that
pushing a decade of working in Russia
and we've done a lot of things in Russia
what I want to talk about today is
really this overarching question one of
the burning questions that we've had is
where is the epidemic going in Russia
what are the transmission dynamics what
is the trajectory what does the future
of the HIV epidemic look like in Russia
and this is a really important question
and I'll show you why so I'm going to
begin with a brief history of the HIV
epidemic in Russia a little bit of the
context and then talk about why we're
concerned about the trajectory so this
slide from UN aids shows the number of
people living with HIV in Russia from
1990 up through 2007 and you can see
that during most of the 1990s there was
not significant spread of HIV in Russia
that the epidemic didn't really take
hold until about the year 2000 and it's
interesting to note that because in the
1990s most of the rest of the world was
in fact experiencing growing HIV
epidemic so Russia is one of these
countries along with several others in
Eastern Europe that we consider to be
late comers to the HIV epidemic so to
provide some context for that I think
it's important to think about the
political change that has happened in
Russia you know in the night prior to
the 1990s Russia was a communist state
and then in 1991 there was this
transition really permiten many of you
were probably too young for this but I
remember it a really remarkable
transition from a communist state to a
federal republic with many elements of a
democratic government there was free
market economy that was trying to be
established and open borders which when
we think about transmission of
infectious diseases open borders is
something really important to think
about but because of this rapid
political transition there was a period
of economic chaos in the 1990s or
collapse be a little more dramatic with
reduced domestic gross product
increase poverty and unemployment and
sort of any time you have open borders
and a depressed economy there's a real
opportunity for illegal drug markets to
emerge and so this did happen in Russia
predominantly heroin coming through
Afghanistan so because of these economic
changes there were some social changes
that accompany this as well again with
this mobility you know people coming in
and going there was also a proliferation
of drug use these markets that was
supply created the demand if you will
and for a subset of drug users
commercial sex work really became much
more prolific not to say it didn't exist
in the Soviet era but it became much
more common and much more visible as a
way of people supporting their drug
habits so this really created an
environment in the 1990s which once the
virus entered Russia real opportunity
for spread its really kind of like the
perfect storm if you will for an
emerging HIV epidemic so this really is
not unlike what has happened in other
parts of the world you can see this
white slide the white part of the slide
on the Left shows HIV epidemics among
injection drug users from around the
world you can see explosive growth in
Edinburgh Bangkok Myanmar cities in
China so where the virus was present
there was opportunities for these
rapidly emerging epidemics and certainly
we saw that happen all over the world
I've added to this published graph my
own date our own data from Kaliningrad
togliatti City and st. Petersburg three
Russian cities showing the same thing
okay what's so this again is not unique
we've seen this before but what's
troubling about this is the fact that
these epidemics emerged in the 1980s
when HIV was new we didn't know a lot
about it we didn't understand how it was
transmitted we didn't fully understand
how could be prevented but that changed
over the course of these epidemics in
many of these cities at New York City is
a great example have really experienced
reversals in their HIV epidemic among
drug users because we now know about the
virus we know how to prevent it we know
what is effective prevention so at a
time so it's troubling to me that this
is happening at a time when we know how
to prevent HIV transmission among drug
users we can talk more about that later
but so this is the current situation so
because of this rapidly growing epidemic
there are now a prot an estimated
approximate 1 million people living in
Russia who have HIV consider the entire
Russian populations about 145 million so
less than half of the population of the
US but they have about almost a million
people living with HIV so when you look
at this map this color tells you that
the HIV prevalence among adults now
exceeds 1 percent it looks a lot like
many countries in sub-saharan Africa
where the epidemic has been spreading
for decades so this is troubling now
many of the people counted in this
prevalence estimate are in fact
injection drug users but it begs the
question you know these are considered
generalized epidemics it begs the
question of whether or not Russia is
headed toward a more generalized
epidemic currently the epidemic is
concentrated among drug users but is
that shifting this is what we don't know
there is some evidence that there's
increasing spread of HIV to the general
the so-called general population so not
among drug users national surveillance
data showed that in 2001 only four
percent of newly registered cases of HIV
were due to heterosexual transmission
again most of it being among drug users
but by 2010 there was this remarkable
shift now forty percent of newly
reported HIV cases in Russia are
heterosexually acquired so some evidence
of a shift we were involved in a study
with some colleagues in st. Petersburg
who did a study looking they interviewed
people who hit a court newly diagnosed
with HIV who were not drug user
so they had acquired it heterosexually
and they asked them about their drug
partners about their sex partners and
were their sex partners also drug users
so in 2005 fifty percent of people with
heterosexual acquired HIV could say I
have a sex partner who's a drug user
this number went down in 2008 it was
only thirty-seven percent so this seems
to reflect this spread okay people who
are heterosexually getting HIV are less
likely to be directly connected to a
drug user so that's the background
that's a situation a rapidly growing
epidemic that frankly doesn't show a
whole lot of signs of slowing
predominantly among drug users but
concern for spread to be on drug users
so the work the framework that has
guided a lot of our work has been this
theory of core groups in infectious
disease epidemiology so this is the
framework that we use to study this
phenomenon so core groups can be
individuals core groups are individuals
toward high risk for HIV acquisition and
transmission there are multiple ways to
define core groups being a behavioral
epidemiologist I've chosen to think
about core groups behaviorally what are
the behaviors that people engage in that
put them at risk for acquiring
transmitting HIV so for example
injection drug users men who have sex
with men and female sex workers can be
considered a core group for HIV
transmission because of the behaviors in
which they engage bridge populations
then our non-core individuals but
individuals who have direct contact with
the core so these are people who by
definition are not drug users MSM or sex
workers but they have contact with the
core so for example the non-id you sex
partners of drug users this is a
potential bridge population the female
sex partners of MSM is another one and
the male clients of female sex workers
so these are people who we might
consider to be bridge population and
then the general population is really
everybody else non-core individuals who
do not have direct contact with the core
now I want to pause for just a moment
because I realized this language can be
off-putting to some we're basically
labeling people based on behaviors with
regard to their potential for
transmitting HIV and I end these in
there narrowly defined so realize this
can be off-putting I don't mean to label
anybody but I do think it's important to
talk about these people and to talk
about what's going on we have to call
them something so for example you know
everybody's part of the general
population when I talk about the general
population I'm talking about non-core
individuals who don't have direct
contact with the core that just gets
very wordy so I'll call them general
population right without trying to label
anybody it's just a way of getting the
dialogue moving here's the same thing in
a picture and you're going to see this
picture few more times during my
presentation so I'll just take a moment
to orient you again these are members of
the Corps behaviorally defined at high
risk for HIV they could be either IDU
MSM or sex workers they mix with
themselves but they also mix have
contact with people outside the core
some of these folks have contact with
some people out here so core bridge in
general lots of permutations of how
people are mixing but general framework
so as I said we've been working in
Russia since about two thousand three on
a variety of different studies so today
I'm going to talk about four and I'm
gonna do it quickly mindful of the time
we have done work with injection drug
users and their non IDU sex partners
we've done work with MSM and their
female sex partners we've done work with
female sex workers and their male
clients the most recent body of work
I've been involved in that's
particularly exciting to me at this
moment in time is male sex workers we
don't know who they're having sex with
this is a population about which very
little is known so I put the question
marks here our work was really designed
to figure out are they a core group and
could there possibly be bridging at this
point in time we didn't know but so I'm
going to go through each of these
studies quickly lets you know kind of
our key findings a lot of these studies
a lot more work has been done than what
I'm going to present today today I
really just want to focus on the key
findings that we have related to this
potential for spread of the HIV epidemic
so I'll do the injection drug users
first so we did a study in st.
Petersburg Russia affectionately known
as Seth cap which stands for the sexual
acquisition and transmission of HIV it
was a cooperative agreement study this
we were one site of several all the
other sites were in the US and the
overarching goal of this was to do
exactly what I said we've been wanting
to do to look at the potential for HIV
transmission within the core and beyond
the core in these two populations that
we know where high risk for HIV drug
users in men who have sex with men so we
did a cross-sectional study between 2005
2008 that was when we collected the data
our participants included drug users men
who have sex with men and their sex
partners and we recruited this sample
through respondent driven sampling which
is a form of chain referral so we
identified some drug users who came into
the study and then we gave them coupons
to bring in their friends who they knew
were drug users and so on and so on
and for data collection we did an
interview and we did testing for HIV and
other sexually transmitted infections
that's all I'm going to say about the
methods I could say a whole lot more
about the methods but I really want to
focus on the results because they're
interesting and I'm happy to take
questions about the methods either at
the end or at any other time I just this
is not a methods talk so here are the
results so we recruited 631 drug users
in this study who reported on 709 sex
partnerships so the first things a lot
of data on the slide so I'll go through
it kind of slowly the first thing to
know the HIV prevalence among these drug
users was forty-five percent which is
really high and I'll come back and show
you how high that is an eighty-four
percent of the drug users in our sample
reported being sexually active they're
young the drug users in st. Petersburg
tend to be young they're very sexually
active let me ask them about their sex
partners fifty-four percent of them
reported having sex with other drug
users okay so this is you know sexual
transmission but within the core if you
will if they're having sex with other
drug users but forty percent of them
reported these types of partnerships
forty percent of the drug users said
they were having sex with someone who
was not a drug user so this is the
potential for bridging we're talking
about and in those relationships
forty-one percent reported having unsafe
sex so high HIV high levels of sexual
activity in a fair amount of mixing okay
across these groups and suboptimal
condom use we were interested in sort of
characterizing these relationships like
who what are these relationships so we
did that we looked at a variety of
different factors to see if we could
characterize them and the thing that I
found most interesting is that these
bridging relationships were most often
reported by mail ID you so the common
pattern is that the mail is the
injection drug user and the sex partner
the non drug using sex partner is female
so there are lots of interesting things
we could talk about around relation
dynamic
but they were more highly educated which
I can't really explain that these were
more likely to be main partnerships
relationships where there was a
purported level of commitment and I
suppose the good news is that condom use
was reported more frequently in these
bridging relationships so condom use was
more likely to be used in these
relationships than in these
relationships so that's good for these
guys you know it's not great for these
guys because they should be using
condoms too we were able in this study
to recruit a small number of these
members of the bridge population ok so
the drug users came in they did our
survey we said would you be willing to
bring in your sex partners who don't use
drugs some of them did we got a total of
53 not a huge number not an easy
population to reach but what we found is
fifteen percent of these people we're in
fact HIV positive okay and so these are
non drug users having sex with drug
users and that's their positivity they
also had what in my opinion is a fairly
high level of sexual risk for HIV and
other STI so a majority of them reported
at least one what we call high-risk
sexual behavior either having recent new
sex partners reporting unsafe sex or
having multiple partners so they're
having sex with a drug user they some of
them have HIV and they have a pretty
risky sexual profile so I'm going to
summarize the IDU before I move on to
the other populations just so it all
sticks I conclude from these data that
the potential for bridging of HIV that
is HIV transmission between drug users
and their sex partners is real and maybe
even high this high prevalence in the
core that forty five percent prevalence
in the core certainly suggests
transmission can happen the high levels
of sexual activity of the drug users
including many of them having non-drug
using sex partners and also the
high-risk behaviors among these
potential Bridgers plus the fact
HIV appears to have seated in this
population so this is something that it
is concerns me okay I'll come back to
the IDE when we tie it all together so
now I want to move into the second
population I'm going to do for so these
are men who have sex with men so the
study we did of men who have sex with
men is the same study that I just
presented the South cap study so i won't
do the methods here I do just want to
show some pictures um this is a picture
of st. Petersburg a historical picture
of nevsky prospekt so anybody who's been
to st. Petersburg has probably been to
nevsky prospekt it's one of the main
roads in a very nice part of town the
hotels for I stare right along this road
I walk this road all the time and this
is a bridge okay that goes over I
believe it's a canal the phone ponca is
a canal right yeah and marking this
bridge are these four statues and these
are really beautiful statues this is
what they look like today they're called
the [ __ ] stammers and they're really
they're really beautiful and I think
they're a an important landmark in st.
Petersburg well-known landmark in st.
Petersburg so I show these to you today
because they also appear on the cover of
a brochure that you can get in st.
Petersburg today about gay st.
Petersburg so this is a brochure that
I've scanned in and here's the statue on
that bridge I just showed you this was
published in 2007 and it says at the
bottom I don't know if you can read it
this is a queer map of st. Petersburg
and you open up it's like this you know
multifold brochure and you open it up
and it's all about gay life in st.
Petersburg so there's websites to go to
and there are clubs to go to this one is
a club called bunker and I'm going to
come back and we're going to talk more
about bunker in a minute I think the
point of this is that gay life is very
present in st. P
eters burg it is somewhat open it's not
completely open it's probably more open
than other places in Russia but maybe
not as open as other places in the world
but the point is that it exists it's
there so it's really important that we
understand what their risks are for HIV
so this same figure so we looked at the
potential for bridging by men who have
sex with men we recruited 253 men who
have sex with men in this study who
reported on 564 sex partnerships and
here's what we found so again this is
very parallel to what I showed you
before ten percent of the MSM in this
study were in fact HIV infected but
what's interesting is to look at that
some of the men who have sex with men
also reported being injection drug users
so if you separate that out among the
non injection drug users the prevalence
was seven percent and among the drug
users the prevalence was forty-five
percent so this looks an awful lot like
the estimate among the drug users i just
presented so this is an interesting
group but among the non drug using men
who have sex with men HIV problems was
about seven percent very sexually active
ninety-four percent of them reported
being sexually active so if you look at
who they're having sex with again here
they are in the core most of them
ninety-five percent of their sex
partners were reported to be other men
and only five percent reported having a
female sex partner so again this is that
potential for bridging that we talked
about transmission within the core is
important but when you think about
bridging only five percent of their sex
partners were female however about a
third of the time in those relationships
they weren't using condoms
so similar to the IDU we wanted to try
to describe these guys so how are these
guys you know different from these guys
those that have the potential for
bridging versus those who don't we
looked at a lot of factors to see if we
could distinguish these two groups of
MSM the only factor that emerged was
drug use so the men who have sex with
men who are also injection drug users
are much more likely to be the ones who
also have a female sex partner okay big
big difference we were able to recruit
an even smaller number of these people
the women the bridge women so these are
the women who report at who we who
report having sex with somebody that
they know was a male sex worker we only
recruited 18 again there weren't many to
recruit because not too many of the men
said they had female sex partners but we
found 18 of them two of them were also
HIV positive those same two women were
also drug users themselves and of of
these 1812 reported new sex partners and
15 reported multiple partners so very
similar to what I showed for the IDU
these potential Bridgers HIV is present
in the population this population has
been seated if you will and they tend to
display a fairly high risk profile for
HIV and STI acquisition and transmission
around things like new partners and
multiple partners
so to summarize the MSM before I go on
at the female sex workers are third
population I think that there is a lower
potential for sexual bridging by MSM
compared to the IDU there's a lower HIV
prevalence right about seven percent in
a relatively small number of female sex
partners but I don't want people to
think oh okay so this is not a problem
it's still a tremendous problem maybe
not for bridging but there are other
problems we need to be concerned about
first of all this could be an
underestimate our colleagues have done
some work with men who have sex with men
in st. Petersburg and believe that that
five percent estimate is too low it's
just you know our one study but other
studies show that a higher proportion of
men who have sex with men do in fact
report having female sex partners twenty
percent thirty percent so this could be
artificially low also this question of
transmission within the core
transmission between men who have sex
with men is something really important
and probably understudied something we
need to think about in this bridging
this the fact that the MSM who also
inject have very high prevalence of HIV
and the fact that they're more likely to
have sex with women they may be a small
group but they may be a really
vulnerable group and one that we don't
know a whole lot about so and could
there be bridging between these two core
groups okay so could the MSM who are
also IDU be a path of entry of HIV from
the idea of community into the MSM
community so some you know questions
that we don't have the answers to at
this point in time so I want to put this
into context because I talk a lot about
how big of a problem this is and I can
say these estimates are high but you may
not believe me so what I want to do is
sort of compare our estimates of HIV
prevalence and incidence from two places
around the world so this is what we
found in our study again 45% prevalence
of HIV among drug users depending on how
you do the math somewhere between six to
fifteen percent HIV prevalence among
these high risk
Oh sexuals an eight percent among MSM so
this is our work so comparing our ID you
estimate so these other estimates I put
up this is not a systematic review it is
not a thorough review it is not a
meta-analysis I simply found some recent
published articles with similar
populations so take it for what it's
worth but you can look and see in
Scotland the HIV prevalence among IDU is
two percent Canada 12% New York City 12%
okay and these incidence rates in st.
Petersburg we estimated to be about
fourteen percent per year the incidence
in Scotland less than one percent per
year New York less than one percent per
year Canada three percent per year so
really no matter how you look at it the
HIV epidemic in Russia is I mean I'm all
set a loss for words it's extreme and
probably unlike any epidemic happening
anywhere else in the world maybe I'm
being overly dramatic I think I mean
certainly Ukraine Estonia I mean are the
other places in Eastern Europe could
have seen something similar but when you
think about how big Russia is in the st.
Petersburg is a city of five million
it's really kind of I mean it certainly
takes my breath away how serious this is
okay high-risk heterosexuals in Scotland
about a one-percent prevalence in New
York City about a nine percent
prevalence so what we're seeing in st.
Petersburg among the so-called high risk
heterosexuals is not unlike what we see
in other places again the point being
that HIV is present in these populations
and therefore we need to think about how
that could change over time for MSM you
can see prevalence estimates in the UK
from five to twelve percent Australia
eight percent Rhode Island two percent
San Francisco twenty-seven percent South
Africa twenty-six percent so our
estimate of eight percent is certainly
not showing the highest burden of HIV
among MSM in st. Petersburg there are
other places where the burden is greater
but not unlike a lot of other places in
the world as well so just to put this
into context i hope this sort of gives
you some sense for why we think these
estimates are somewhat problematic so I
want to move on to the third population
female sex workers and their sex
partners I don't know if this image
projects very well but these are in fact
female sex workers in Russia this
picture was taken by one of our
colleagues that are partnering NGO
Stella in st. Petersburg and you know
one of the things that really struck me
when I started doing work with female
sex workers in Russia so these are women
who so first I should say female sex
work in Russia is quite varied and the
work that I've done has focused on the
street based sex workers so there's
brothel based escort based hotel based I
mean it you know but we're talking about
the street base sex workers so you can
see them on the street and we talk a lot
in HIV about studying vulnerable
populations and hidden populations and
one of the things that really struck me
is that is this is not a hidden
population I mean these women are
actually quite easy to find and talk to
the locations where they work these
women are standing on a road it's like a
commuter road that goes from the central
city to the suburbs and then know where
to find them and we know where to find
them so vulnerable yes hidden probably
not so much so the question around
bridging so these women have I mean we
talk a lot about research focused on
these women again the bridging question
is one about whether or not their male
clients could play a role in bridging
HIV in st. Petersburg most of the street
based sex workers are in fact injection
drug users a vast majority of them and
they have a high HIV prevalence last
estimated in 2003 was forty-eight
percent so given the high prevalence
given their work could this be a
potential path of transmission so
studies have been done all over the
globe looking at the role of male
clients and HIV transmission this had
never been done anywhere in Russia so we
thought it was important to take a look
so we did a pilot study which included a
formative phase to develop a typology we
really wanted
to describe this phenomenon of the male
clients of the street based sex workers
and our colleague olga lapina who's here
with us today very elegantly wrote up
the findings of that and it's being
published in the applied anthropology
journal human organization I would be
delighted to share that with people so
that was one thing was really to
describe this phenomenon and so we've
done that the other thing was we wanted
to know can we recruit these guys like
can we get them to participate in a
research study and if we can what can we
learn from them the women the sex
workers if they would bring in their
clients when they did bring in their
clients we asked their clients to bring
in their friends who they knew to also
purchase sex we also tried street
intercept so actually going to where the
women are working and getting the
clients that way and clinician referrals
from a city STI clinic we asked the
clinician to refer patients who he knew
had purchased sex so we did a structured
face-to-face interview with the men who
we got in the study asked a bunch of
questions a lot of this work happened on
the van so this is the outreach van that
is run by Stella again which is our
partnering NGO in st. Petersburg so this
is the Vance is what it looks like and
it goes out to where the women are
working and the women can come on the
van and talk to the doctors she's a
psychiatrist and she's a gynecologist
and they get services they get condoms
they get referrals for health care and
they get social support they get a bunch
of things so what we'd actually this is
Natasha and she actually did most of the
interviews for this particular project
so the women would come on the van they
would get their condoms they'd get their
services whatever needs questions they
had those were all met and then they
were offered if they wanted to bring
their clients in for a research study
and those who agree we gave them coupons
to give to their clients to come and be
in the study
so we recruited 62 clients during a
nine-week period most of the clients
came in because they were referred by
the female sex workers or through their
peers and smaller numbers through these
other methods participation I thought
was pretty good our goal was 60 so we
achieved that goal we actually got 62 we
did use this coupon method of you know
giving coupons to the women to give to
their clients and then giving coupons to
the clients to give to their friends
it's a little bit difficult to calculate
an exact response rate but I can say
that 112 coupons were given and 60 men
came in with their coupons so over half
so that's pretty good and I can also say
this isn't quantitative this is
anecdotal but when I was in st.
Petersburg a couple years ago I had the
opportunity to go out on the van to ride
on the van while this work was going on
and I was surprised we pulled up to a
corner where the women are known to work
in congregate and we pulled up and there
were a bunch of men there standing with
their coupons they wanted to come on and
do the yeah we really provided you know
compensation for this so I think they
were you know doing it for that as well
but the men I one night I was there and
again it was only one night but we they
interviewed several men on the van they
were there they knew about the study no
shame no nothing embarrassing about it
they wanted to be in the study and they
were interviewed right in front of me so
my impression was that they were willing
to participate some of them of course we
don't know about the men who aren't
willing to participate that's a whole
nother story about bias I'm not going to
talk about so here's what they said so
we interviewed these guys again the male
clients of the female sex workers they
reported having on average five point
four sex partners in the past 12 months
and three point six of whom were female
sex partners interestingly for bridging
seventy-four percent of these guys also
reported having non sex worker sex
partners so like girlfriends wives etc
and in these relationships with the non
sex worker sex partners most
the sex was unprotected okay not using
condoms another way to think about this
we use this model to describe bridging
this was published by people who done
similar work in somewhere in Asia I
forget we classified our sample
according to the likelihood that they
could play a role in bridging of HIV so
men who reported not using condoms all
the time with both sex workers and non
sex workers we consider them active
Bridgers men who reported using condoms
all the time with sex workers but not
all the time with their non sex workers
sex partners those are potential
Bridgers and then the guys who said they
use condoms all the time with everybody
are unlikely Bridgers okay so if you
look at it that way over half our sample
fifty-eight percent of our sample
reported some potential for bridging
because they're having sex with both sex
workers and non sex workers and their
reporting suboptimal condom use so over
half could play a role in bridging I'm
going to skip that we ask the clients
about their behaviors with their non sex
worker sex partners forty percent of the
time it involved alcohol much less
frequently drugs were involved but about
half the time they were not using
condoms so these are the nature of these
relationships so to sum that up what we
think we now might know about female sex
workers and their clients the potential
for these clients to play a role in
bridging is real its present I mean over
half of these men are classified as
active or potential Bridgers many of
them three-quarters of them have non
female sex or non female sex workers sex
partners so that's a path a potential
path of transmission suboptimal condom
use with both sex worker and non sex
worker partners infrequent alcohol use
so I actually skipped it but it will go
back alcohol use was involved about half
the time in their contacts with sex
workers
fairmont alcohol use fair amount of
mixing and not a lot of condom use says
that transmission certainly is possible
in that population although I'm in our
study was too small we didn't test for
HIV in the clients so the last work I
want to talk about is the most recent
work we've done with male sex workers so
this is sort of the fourth and final
population that could play a role in
transmission dynamics of HIV in Russia
and this is a picture from a tourist
brochure of Catherine's Park you know
Russia I don't know who's been it's
really it's a beautiful city and this is
a beautiful park also on nevsky prospekt
the same street I talked about before
and this is a statue of Catherine the
Great it was one of the great Empress's
of Russia in the Imperial era she ruled
the later half of the 1700s and i think
is widely renowned is one of the
greatest rulers i guess you just don't
get the great after your name for no
reason right so she's Catherine the
Great she was also so that's all true
she was also well known or it has been
widely reported or believed that another
defining characteristic is that she had
a great many number of lovers so that's
going to become relevant it's
interesting when I come back to this in
a minute by the way great book did you
finish it great book just came out last
year called Catherine the Great about
500 pages by Robert Massey who's written
a lot of books about Russia a fabulous
story of it's a think of won the
Pulitzer Prize for maybe anyway I'm
about halfway done with it so I'm not an
expert on Catherine the Great yet but
it's a good read anyway we'll come back
to her so male sex workers we started
this work knowing very little about male
sex workers there was one study done in
two thousand one that interviewed 434
MSM from gay clubs in st. Petersburg and
two-thirds of them reported they had
ever sold sex for money more recent work
done by our colleagues in st. Petersburg
I think I don't have those data but I
think show a similar thing so this said
we know they exist a recent study from
Moscow just published last year's
reported the eighteen percent of the
male sex workers in that relatively
small sample were in fact HIV positive
so about all we know about male sex
workers in st. Petersburg is that they
exist and they may be at risk for HIV
that's it so we felt it was important to
learn a little bit more about them so we
designed a study to look at the
feasibility of recruiting them into a
research study we actually wrote a much
larger grant to do this and it didn't
get funded because the reviewers said we
you have not demonstrated you can access
this population so we said fine so we
did a pilot study to show we can access
this population we also wanted to gather
preliminary data about HIV related
factors risk factors things that
influence HIV and risk to inform future
larger studies in particular we wanted
to know we want to describe the variety
of male sex work we want to know a
little bit about their HIV risks and
related behaviors so we designed a
qualitative study which was really
appropriate for this qualitative
research is very useful when you don't
know a lot about your topic and you need
to learn it's also very useful for
generating hypotheses it's really more
about depth over Brett so talking to a
smaller number of people learning all
you can to to hear their experiences in
their own words and to try to derive
meaning from that to guide other studies
so we did this qualitative study that
included in-depth interviews we audio
recorded and transcribed these
interviews and then we did the ematic
coding by three members of the research
team so myself Elizabeth King and ksenia
Ritson sitting in the audience and this
is
I took this picture yesterday in my
office and we're actually coding writing
you can see the coffee and the
transcripts and how much fun we're
having like we really this has been I
don't know you can talk to Elizabeth and
ksenia about it because I may be like
over bubbly but it's really been fun
like we've had a good time and we're
just beginning right this is i should
say this is a work in progress we have a
lot more to do we haven't analyzed all
the data but what we've done so far has
been enlightening and i'm really
grateful to the experience and and and
time from my colleagues because i
couldn't have done it without them but
all mistakes are my own so our sample we
talked to 12 male sex workers in eight
other key informants the male sex
workers we recruited by the internet
through professional contacts people who
are collaborators in st. Petersburg know
to be male sex workers and by peer
referrals when one sweet'eart started
talking to a guy we asked if he could
bring in other guys in the median age of
these guys was 22 so they're young the
key informants we talked to represented
NGOs in st. Petersburg that are well
known to provide services for MSM gay
clubs and one researcher and they were
recruited by a variety of methods as
well so what I'm going to do now again
this is a work in progress but I want to
share with you what some of the emergent
themes have been so far and what we've
learned so the first thing we learned
from these interviews is that male sex
work is fairly widespread among MSM but
it really depends on your definition so
pretty much everybody we talked to said
oh yeah it's common I know a bunch of
guys you know nobody nobody said it
wasn't common or widespread but it
really depends on your definition around
what is exchanged so there can be
exchange of money but there can be less
formal exchanges so things like clothes
or meals and restaurants in that kind of
thing so these are just some quotes that
are illustrative of this one guy said
yes it is common another guy said the
practice happens a great deal in
different situations in different ways
and the third respondent when asked
about the material exchange is it
necessarily for money or could it be
something else trips to restaurants were
buying clothes he said oh this is far
more common so it really gives you a
sense that it happens a lot but that
there's a lot of variability it's not
always this clear exchange of money for
sex one of the things we really wanted
to do was to describe the variety of
male sex work in st. Petersburg and this
turned out to be very complicated these
men you know they can be described on a
variety of dimensions so we selected for
simplicity for a first pass as a way to
begin the process we selected location
of recruitment of client as one way to
classify again like I said before when I
talk about you know corbridge in general
it's not that these are mutually
exclusive or not fluid it's just that
this is a useful way to start talking
about it so we selected one dimension
and found one way to describe the male
sex workers is by where they recruit
clients so I'm going to go through each
of these and again because this is
qualitative research there will be no p
values there will be no confidence
intervals just illustrative quotes to
support the themes that we feel have
emerged from the data so coming back to
Catherine's garden I showed that to you
before here's another picture of
Catherine's garden in the winter time
that I took when i was there a few years
ago Katherine's garden emerged as one of
the places where male sex work happens
several people talked about Catherine's
park is a location one of the guys
talked about yeah in the summer time I
sit on the benches and in the winter
time I walk around the park in the
wintertime is very cold so you don't
want to sit but so people talk about
sitting on these benches as a way of
soliciting clients the men who work in
Catherine's garden tend to be young
sometimes younger than 16 and
economically very vulnerable this is a
place that is this location is well
known to both
locals and tourists foreigners who come
know about the park and what's available
there the interesting thing is that we
don't really know anymore what the
volume of male sex work in this location
is several people talked about it being
used less frequently in part because of
the emergence of the Internet you don't
have to go stand here if you have a
computer to solicit clients also
homophobia it could be risky to be
standing out here and to be identified
as a male sex worker law enforcement the
police are often present in these places
so for a variety of reasons the volume
of sex work happening in these locations
may be declining so here are some quotes
there is such a place catkin garden but
who was there now those who have no
access to the internet and this the
lowest layers another it's cheap boys
who work for a piece of bread the other
location that emerged was the Moscow
railway station somebody said you know
boys are constantly approached I think
they have not yet attained the age of 16
and offer some fun in the toilet but
over time this community has been
eliminated so historically it's happened
there the degree to which is happening
there now we just don't know so the
internet one thing probably the single
clearest emergency is that the Internet
has greatly facilitated the occurrence
of male sex work in Russia and it can
occur in a variety of ways so this
picture I show this to be illustrative
of the fact that you can go to these
well-known websites this was gay da true
and literally I think it was like three
clicks my Russian colleagues I won't say
who helped me with this because I can't
read the Russian but literally three
clicks in here you are and this is
Maxine I I blacked out the eyes he
didn't black him out I maybe he doesn't
mind but I minded so I blocked him out
and I also blocked out his phone number
and his slogan is maximum sex with
Maxine and he goes on to describe
himself his age his height his weight
some other dimensions
and what and then he goes on and
describes eight thousand rubles for
active sex six thousand rubles for
passive sex so he's putting his pricey
he'll come to your apartment you can go
to his apartment he's up for anything
except dirty sex I don't not sure what
he dirty is for him but he's up for
anything but dirty sex and his phone
number and it was like the easiest thing
in the world to find this guy so just as
a way of illustrating how this can
happen on the Internet quite easily but
it does happen in a variety of ways so
there are some websites that are more
dating websites but there are ways on
these dating websites of indicating that
you're also interested in commercial
relationships so for example a couple
quotes the internet definitely the wall
on BBS website dating sites sometimes
you admire someone's appearance you
write him a compliment and he replies I
am 5,000 rubles for two hours on the
Mamba website a profile highlighted in
pink means he is offering sex for money
and those who surf the internet pay
attention to it yes via the internet the
idea came into my head I placed the ad
the man replied nowadays progress using
the internet is not difficult what do
you use to find clients boards usually
dating sites so a tremendous amount of i
would say volume of sex work happening
via the internet there are also clubs in
saunas in st. Petersburg where sex can
be exchanged transactionally most of the
respondents we talked to could very
readily name for you the three or four
clubs in three or four gay clubs in st.
Petersburg these clubs are well known
everybody could name them but the thing
to note about these clubs is that they
don't exist for transactional sex these
are clubs their entertainment clubs
people go for bands people go to
socialize people go to meet romantic
partners people may even go for
anonymous sex but that's not necessarily
transactional sex so they really exist
not for transactional sex but several
men reported transactional sex does
occur in these settings so this is
Booker the
love that was advertised on the brochure
i showed you before this is the enter
and these are pictures on their website
like these are the seller advertising
like i just went to the bunker website
and these were there we didn't take the
pictures actually i think my colleagues
were not allowed into bunker because
they're female you have to be male so we
can't get in but they put their pictures
on the website and these are what they
refer to as cabins or places where sex
can occur so a couple of quotes Blue
Oyster Central Station the club you know
they're like naming these clubs and the
interviewer said there may be commercial
sex and dating yes of course Central
Station is more for commercial purposes
there is a dark room but the money is
still more through the internet where it
can all be negotiated when there is
correspondents so again coming back to
the ease of using the internet and then
describing bunker there are several
toilet stalls with a hole in the wall
below the belt there are several mazes
where all this can happen and then he
goes on to say there is not even music
only pornography on the screen so
there's a real range of these types of
clubs sorry I'm looking at the time I'm
all her yet but I'm almost done so what
I've described up till now are the guys
who work alone individually we did also
uncover sex work that occurs in a more
organized fashion through the use of
agencies or pimps whatever you want to
call it so like for example one guy said
I've never seen him but he calls me and
says you have to drive to the hotel his
agency is in Moscow he added me on the
Internet I transfer the money through
the terminal using a bank card he takes
thirty to forty percent yes he has his
own website so again the internet even
being used for agency based sex work the
advantages and disadvantages were well
described I think that first quote is
sufficient the big disadvantage to
working with an agency is that you have
to give them part of your earnings but
the benefit is that someone else does
the work for you around identifying
clients
so I've described the main types but I
think it's important to note that these
descriptions may not be representative
mutually exclusive or complete those
types were widely described by most of
the people we talked to but we did
Undercover uncover a couple of other
types of male sex work so this first
quote you know there are pretty nice
guys who know their own worth if they
make suggestions they say I'm three
hundred thousand rubles per month if you
want to be with me it's like a thousand
dollars I think yeah turns out to be
something like a marriage of convenience
and then the final group that we really
did not uncover in our work but I
continue to think about are the male sex
workers who are involved in drug use so
this was a quote actually from one of
the outreach workers saying our jails
our prison camps they are predisposed to
this men having sex with men and many
receive their first experience there
that is they are drug addicts and in
their addiction their usage they will
search for any way to get these drugs
and then they go on and say some people
steal those who can't steal these people
are inclined to get money through sex so
we did not talk we talked to a guy who
fit this profile so I'm pretty sure they
exist we didn't actually talk to any
male sex workers who reported drug
addiction so kind of an open question
couple more topics very quickly around
HIV risk perceived risk for HIV was
almost universally reported but in a
really abstract way so the guys were all
like yeah I mean everybody's at risk
sure i'm at risk but it wasn't a very
salient thing there wasn't a lot of
personal experience people were not
saying yes i'm a risk because of my
behaviors or yes i'm at risk I have
friends who I know where HIV infected it
was things like of course there is risk
for HIV even condom manufacturers do not
provide one hundred percent guarantee
that during sex condom will not burst
slip or break another respondent when
asked do you think you are risk for HIV
he said well certainly but and then he
did the Russian equivalent of knocking
on wood he actually spit over his left
shoulder I'm told is the you know
Russian equivalent you know it's like so
it's not this like these are my
behaviors this is how the virus is
transmitted it's more like yeah sure but
you know which is a scary thing so the
risk seem to be abstract not salient
condom use o people I say oh yeah yeah I
use condoms I use condoms but then when
you probe you find out that they don't
use condoms all the time they don't use
condoms if they're offered more money
they don't use condoms if it's oral sex
they don't use condoms sometimes they're
just caught up in the moment right like
this guy caught up in the moment they
don't use client don't use condoms if
they're with known clients like oh I
knew the guy wasn't my first time you
know and a couple of the guys reported
not using condoms with women so it's
like yeah yeah condoms we use them and
then you find out that often they don't
and this is actually very similar to
what we've learned from female sex
workers my final topic is about alcohol
use this was commonly reported but
mostly moderate primarily to relax so
the guys would say in the club you take
yourself a shot of vodka for ease of
gate well plus for courage you can drink
if you like sometimes they offer a drink
a glass of wine whiskey and coke but
we're not drunk drink a glass and relax
like a couple of the guys noted it's not
good to get drunk right because they
have a job to perform and it could be
difficult to do that if they're too
drunk so they drink a little bit to
relax so this is really a work in
progress I believe this is a diverse
group that requires multiple strategies
for research recruitment and I'm
concerned enough about their risk for
HIV based on their limited risk
perception their alcohol use and not
always using condoms to think that more
research with these guys is is going to
be important I will make this my final
slide I think that the force of HIV
infection in st. Petersburg remains
among injection drug users transmission
to their partners is likely the degree
to which it's going to go beyond their
partners into this so-called general
population we're a little less certain
but clearly the drug users and their
partners are at risk male sex MSM and
male sex workers may be playing a
smaller role in bridging but HIV is
present
in these populations in non-trivial
amounts so spread is possible there
might be certain subgroups at risk the
MSM who are also drug users or the male
sex workers who are also drug users
that's a really important thought and
that these groups may be under studied
so I think we really need to do a lot of
continued monitoring in Russia around
this fairly where are we and where are
we going a lot more work needs to be
done to understand much better what the
risks are here